[Musique]
alors bienvenue sur ce plateau avec
brigitte klinkert qu'avec nous comment
allez vous bonsoir très bien accrochez
vous est bon dit ravi de vous accueillir
vous êtes conseillère départementale
dans canton de colmar 2 avec votre
binôme eric jeux 3ds que c'est un long
fleuve tranquille d'être concert
départementale en tout cas c'est
passionnant
si on aime les gens et si on a envie de
faire avancer des dossiers aux locaux
c'est passionnant alors justement on a
demandé adria l'habile journaliste
alsace20 de vous suivre qu'on découvre
un petit peu le quotidien comme cela des
élus donc il est parti ça a été au menu
avec votre binôme eric straumann remise
de décorations dégustation de choucroute
fête paroissiale mais pas que regarder
une promenade en barque dans la petite
venise peut-être l'une des plus belle
façon de découvrir colmar mais
aujourd'hui nous avons préféré suivre
eric straumann sur les routes de son
canton
où seule la section alsacienne de
l'association nationale de l'ordre
national du mérite il tient son
assemblée générale au programme remise
de décorations et dépôt d'une gerbe au
monument aux morts
maintenant direction red bear ou a lieu
la fête de la choucroute dimanche
ordinaire du mois d'octobre on mesure
déjà le dynamisme du tissu associatif
c'est une petite commune de moins de 500
habitants qui sert celui can 2000 sur
route voyez quel est l'engagement de la
population autour de cette fête qui
témoigne aussi
doté de cette vitalité de la vie
associative et de l'engagement de chacun
des citoyens autour de la vie de la cité
on quitte riedwihr pour aller prendre le
café à colmar la paroisse allez y donne
cet automne
[Musique]
poumon économique du nord du département
colmar et le lieu d'échangés intenses le
conseil départemental s'est engagé
depuis longtemps dans une politique de
développement durable et propose des
alternatives à la voiture individuelle
ici ce sont des bus interurbains et là
un réseau de pistes cyclables le
département depuis une quinzaine
d'années à une politique très
volontariste en matière de pistes
cyclables
nous avons des 2/3 pénétrante qui
viennent de delhaize de colmar elles ont
aujourd'hui quand même il faut bien
reconnaître plutôt une vocation de
loisirs même si de plus en plus de gens
l'utilisent pour aller au travail le
covoiturage est un autre moyen de
diminuer la pollution tout en réduisant
le trafic sur les grands axes c'est
l'une des politiques du département
d'encourager de soutenir et de financer
ces aires de covoiturage vous en avez
une issue du côté de la scène qui a été
je crois a grandi à deux reprises ça
prouve que cette mise à disposition de
cet espace est vraiment utilisé par les
gens en particulier ceux qui se rendent
plutôt vers vers le sud du département
notamment ceux qui travaillent en suisse
cours d'allemand au collège
hector-berlioz ses élèves suivent un
cursus bilingue en plus des cours de
langue des matières comme les maths ou
l'histoire leur sont proposés dans la
langue de goethe on a dégagé avec la
région et département du bas rhin un
million d'euros chaque année pour
soutenir la formation des enseignants et
soutenir l'ouverture de classes
bilingues sa rencontre quand même
aujourd'hui un succès qu'il ne faut pas
négliger mais je pense que c'est encore
insuffisant par rapport aux enjeux qui
se présentent à nous
pour terminer ce tour du canton de
colmar 2 pourquoi ne pas aller déguster
une glace à sundhoffen petite entreprise
familiale les glaces de l'île s'agrandit
pour accueillir les gourmands un nouvel
espace ouvrira bientôt ses portes il a
été financé par elsa by une société de
crédit-bail créée par les deux
départements alsaciens dans les années
70 qu'à l'époque on s'est rendu compte
que le marché les banques
traditionnelles hésité à investir par
exemple en fond de vallée ou dans des
endroits qui leur paraissait pas
attractif et donc alsa bail
a été créée par les collectivités
locales et a permis un certain nombre de
réussites économiques dans la région en
soutenant
là où le marché était défaillant alsa
bail permet le développement
d'entreprises sur tout le territoire
fait remarquable elle dégage des
bénéfices un bel exemple de réussite
alsacienne
voilà ça permet brigitte klinkert de
voir un petit peu sur le terrain ce qui
se passe en fait voilà utilité vraiment
des conseils départementaux alors il
faut savoir que vous vous étiez la seule
femme avant que les lois ne changent et
qui est la parité aujourd'hui vous êtes
16 femmes est ce que ça change quelque
chose pour vous oui déjà il était temps
que je ne sois plus la seule femme parce
que nous sommes au 21e siècle il y avait
une femme sur 31 élus je suis donc très
heureuse aujourd'hui qui est que nous
soyons 16
et c'est vrai que les femmes sont très
présentes au sein de l'assemblée des
partis
sont nées elles sont nous sommes très
engagés très pragmatique et puis on
apporte une sensibilité qui est la nôtre
je trouve ça très bien il est important
que dans une collectivité dans dans un
conseil et bien il ya la parité on est
complémentaires on l'a vu vous étiez sur
le terrain ce dimanche avec eric
straumann c'est important pour vous
cette proximité avec les citoyens c'est
fondamental
on dit aujourd'hui que 9 % des français
font confiance encore aux partis
politiques la proximité
c'est le fait de connaître le terrain le
fait de connaître les personnes le fait
de connaître les dossiers de feld
connaître les problèmes nous sommes les
conseils départementaux et l'ue sur nos
noms c'est un scrutin uninominal et nous
avons donc besoin de cette proximité
vous engager le nombre ni carte voilà
c'est ça on est nous sommes élus sur
notre nom et donc nous avons chaque camp
eric straumann et moi des comptes à
rancy je puis dire à nos électeurs alors
donc si j'ai vu brigitte holle que le
département soutient la filière bilingue
vous seriez pas obligé de le faire et on
a donné le chiffre d'un million d'euros
ce qui est une grosse somme c'est un
arbitrage en fait que le fait le conseil
départemental pourquoi vous vous engagez
dans cette filière bilingue car c'est
une vraie volonté de notre assemblée
départementale comme celle du bas rhin
et de la région parce que c'est un atout
extraordinaire pour les jeunes alsaciens
nous sommes à proximité de l'allemagne à
proximité de la suisse il est important
de connaître la langue du voisin pour le
travail le cas échéant vous le savez qui
a aujourd'hui des emplois vacants en
allemagne juste à quelques kilomètres
d'ici donc pour l'emploi que ce soit en
alsace ou en allemagne ou en suisse il
est important qu'un maximum de jeunes
alsaciens connaissent l'allemand les
formes en voulant donner chance de
trouver du boulot plus facilement voilà
on leur donne une chance de trouver du
boulot et puis une fois qu'on connaît là
bon eh bien il est beaucoup plus facile
d'apprendre d'autres langues et de
devenir plurilingue en plus l'alsacien
l'allemand c'est notre identité
régionale alsacienne alors va également
financer un système de projection 3d
c'est pour l'espace ried brun
à muntzenheim on manque comme ça
d'équipement dans le haut-rhin où dans
de ce genre là à colmar alors bien sûr
il ya des équipements de ce type à
colmar mais il est important pour le
conseil départemental
je suis la présidente de la commission
culture du département de mailler le
territoire
d'équipements et de permettre l'accès à
la culture de tous les haut rhinois
qu'ils soient en zone urbaine ou en zone
rurale impôts encore là dira est là car
vos fusionner il s'agit de quoi alors un
fait les les deux départements haut-rhin
bas-rhin essaye de travailler de manière
très proche ensemble notamment il ya la
grande région qui arriva en 1er janvier
prochain il est important pour les deux
départements de s'unir pour être plus
fort c'est ainsi que nous allons
économique nous avons fusionné nos deux
agences de nous allons fusionner au 1er
janvier les deux agences de
développement économique le quart et la
lira nous allons fusionner au 1er
janvier nos deux agences touristiques
c'est pour être plus fort et pour
marquer aussi nos atouts pour porter
l'alsace dans cette grande région qui
s'ouvre devant nous au 1er janvier vous
anticipez enfin vous serez dans les
clous en fait au 1er janvier on fera
aussi des économies quelque part fin
alors alors l'idée aussi bien sûr c'est
de faire des économies parce que nous
sommes dans un contexte budgétaire très
compliquée en particulier pour les
départements qui ont une charge
budgétaire très lourde dans le domaine
de la solidarité il malheureusement le
contexte économique fait que ça ne va
sûrement pas s'arranger à l'avenir mais
il ya à côté de ce contexte budgétaire
il ya une vraie volonté de travailler
ensemble pour l'alsace sur le social et
la dépendance qui coûte très très cher
ou au département on le sait pour avoir
eu les les présidents de département
qu'est ce que vous faites vous pour
l'accueil des personnes âgées dans votre
canton alors là la preuve l'une des
priorités du conseil départemental du
haut rhin s'est effectivement les
personnes âgées ne serait ce que parce
que la population vieillit dans notre
région et dans notre pays et donc nous
essayons là aussi d'être au plus proche
des familles qui sont souvent un petit
peu désemparé et nous avons mis en place
des pôles gérontologique à travers tout
le département nous aidons bien entendu
aussi à la rénovation et à la
construction des ehpad des maisons de
retraite et puis comme nous la pause la
loi nous versons l'apa c'est-à-dire
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
aux personnes âgées qu'elles soient à
leur domicile pour les aider ou qu'elle
soit en maison de retraite merci pour
toutes ces explications d'origine une
cage rappelle que vous êtes conseillère
départementale dans le canton 2 colbach
canton 2